let's go out to leah in tallahassee
florida
leah how in the world are you i am good
dr d
thanks for being on the team this year
we have all needed it
thank you so much i'm grateful for you
so how can i help
well my sister is dating someone who
my parents and i see as not being
equally yoked
um regarding some of their values
actually
and i'm just having some trouble being
caught in the middle of it
so explain to me what caught in the
middle looks like
uh both parties calling and complaining
about
each other and
i agree with where my parents are at
and i don't necessarily agree with where
my sister is coming from so i'm just
having some difficulties
um with loving them both
and not being caught in the middle not
being that person that they are calling
and complaining to
um yeah
so this is a
classic classic relational triangulation
is what they call it in nerd school
and you have become the point of tension
release for your parents
leaning against your sister and vice
versa and so
the first and most important thing is to
honor everybody is to get out of
your triangle triangulated position back
out
okay um if you allow yourself to be
triangulated by your parents
and your sister then what's gonna happen
is
you're going to end up burning the whole
system to the ground
or you're going to be the flash point by
which they burn the whole system to the
ground
so the best way to step out of this is
this number one tell your parents hey
listen i love my sister i've heard you
guys
i don't want you all to talk bad about
my sister anymore and i know
that's a challenging hard conversation
how old are you by the way
i am 32. yeah there you go so you're an
adult you're a grown woman
um this is a grown-up conversation
that just says hey mom hey dad i can't
do it anymore
um she's my sister she's making
decisions that i don't totally agree
with
but i can't keep going back and forth
between you two and then you sit down
with your sister and have that hard
conversation which is hey listen
i can't have you talking bad about mom
and dad anymore like you're making your
decisions you're
grown up i'm assuming she's a grown up
too is that right
yes okay um and then you lay
your thoughts and opinions down for what
they are and then you love and support
your sister
i guess you could walk away and abandon
your sister whatever the the um
decisions she's making what are they by
the way what are these
decisions she's making they're they're
unequally
yoked i don't really like him what does
unequally yoked mean
well they he's not a christian
and she says that she's very strong in
her beliefs and her values
but it just seems that it's all actually
a lot like a
call before mine um and i just see
this being a struggle for them in their
marriage especially if they bring
kids into the picture if they're not on
the same page with
religion and politics and all of the
above
and it's it's very difficult when
my family believes very strongly
about some of these things so my hard
work
my hard question for you leah is this
why do you get a vote
into how your sister chooses to
live out her faith that she says she has
and live out her loving relationship
which she says she's going to do
because it sounds like you you're
putting a lot of heat and a lot of
she's not thinking this through she's
gonna end up like this
she's gonna have these challenges down
the road and that sounds like
you're bringing your baggage to that
situation
well i've seen how it's worked out in
other family situations
and the hurt that yeah it is
you know her relationship but inevitably
it does affect other family members
especially when kids become involved but
i just
i i just don't want that hurt for her
and for her future
um and the suckiest part about being in
a relationship with somebody
is they can only make that decision for
themselves not you
right and at this point
you have two choices you can speak your
heart and mind and then say
i'll love you and support you or you can
say i don't approve of your
decisions plural and i'm out
i'm not talking to you anymore i'm
breaking up with you as your sister
and i'll tell you i've seen both of
sides of those and one of those
is a treacherous ugly
gut-wrenching um decision that takes
generations to unwind
and the other is frustrating and
annoying but people end up getting
closer and closer over the long term
it's at the end of the day here's the
deal your sister has to make these
decisions
and if she marry somebody who's doesn't
share the same faith
as her will that be hard maybe values
wise yeah they have to have some hard
values conversations
i've also seen folks who say i'm
christian you're a christian we both
love
jesus and they get married and they
never have the values conversation just
like the previous caller right
and loving jesus means something totally
different to one than it does to the
other
and so sometimes the shared religion
helps bypass a conversation about values
that people should have had a long time
ago
and so it may be that your sister enters
into a relationship
that they have to have really hard
direct conversations about what values
looks like and beliefs
are and here's how we're going to raise
our kids we are going to go to church we
are going to do these things
um and at the end of the day it's her
decision and her and her
future husband's decision to make the
challenge then becomes
are your parents going to let those kids
come to thanksgiving
are you gonna be cool aunt leah who's
gonna have the kids over
just because their dad's not a christian
that's the that's the conversation
you're gonna have to make
less about them and their kids now hear
me say this
i don't want for one second to doubt
your heart in this deal
my guess is you really love your sister
and you really want to um
uh you really want her to be loving and
whole and have a great life
but my my guess here also and tell me if
i'm wrong
is that you are you married now
i am i'm married and i have a toddler
okay so
my guess my other guess is you have this
picture
of this this future thanksgiving dinner
this future christmas um this future
birthday party
that this guy and his values and beliefs
or let's just say his beliefs don't fit
into that picture
and suddenly you're having to grieve
this future
fantasy for lack of better words this
future picture that you had for your
family
because your sister's making different
decisions and so really
it's not so much hurtful for me as like
that's more so how my parents feel
and those arguments that start to happen
you know when it's my son's birthday
party it's like guys can't we get along
and not have these arguments and that's
where you as a mom have to
that's exactly right what you just did
you have to draw the boundaries that's
your job which is
hey guys if y'all gonna come to my house
during my kid's birthday party and fight
you're not gonna be welcome here
and those are really hard conversations
between adult kids and their parents
but that's your job as your child's
mom right um that's that's where you
draw the line and say
we're not going to have this
conversation cheer everybody in the
family is welcome at my house
including my sister and her husband and
whatever kids are gonna have all that
that's on you to draw those boundaries
not your parents and quite honestly they
don't get a vote
they don't get a vote and i know that
sounds so harsh and hard and
but they don't oh it's so hard yeah
right it is
so my recommendation to you is this i
recommend that you
call your mom and dad and say hey i want
to have a future talk
about sister and don't do it on the
phone they're going to feel caught off
guard when people get caught off guard
they
they go with their first gut instinct
which is often
not a smart thing they say things that
they can't get back etc say
next saturday i want to have a phone
call with you and dad to talk about
um sister and her fiance
and in that conversation you tell your
mom and dad guys
i'm done talking about this i know how
you feel
i know this idea of unequally yoked i
know there's
um bible verses that say you know
um believers should marry non-believers
and um i get where y'all are coming from
but that's my sister and she knows how
we all feel
and she says she's gonna marry this guy
and she's gonna have a family with this
guy
and i'm gonna love my sister and so from
this point forward mom and dad i am not
a place for you to talk bad about my
sister anymore
and there may be some silence there
there may be some awkwardness there
there may be some well i can't believe
whatever
my guess is over time they will respect
you
deeply for drawing that boundary and if
nothing else
you will respect you for drawing that
boundary and then
have a similar conversation with your
sister which is this
mom and dad have religious beliefs
have faith beliefs that
tell them what you're doing isn't smart
and wise for your heart
it's not smart and wise for your family
and for our family
you believe differently i love you but i
also
am tired of talking about mom and dad
tired of rolling her eyes about mom and
dad i'm tired of beating up mom and dad
so we're done with that i will talk to
you about you and your future husband i
will talk to you about my beautiful
little toddler
your niece or nephew we can talk about
our knuckleheaded husbands or our great
house whatever
but we're not talking about mom and dad
anymore draw the line draw the boundary
because here's the deal at the end of
the day that's all you can control
leah that's the only the only thing you
can do is control your thoughts and your
actions
and if you do have this attitude of
frustration of
judgment of my sister's making the worst
mistake of her life
she might be but they're her decisions
to make
they're her frustrating things to make
and all you can control is your
boundaries my hope is my hope is
is that you'll be honest you'll be up
front and you'll be
clear but at the end of the day your
default setting will be one of
inclusivity and love
that's my hope that's my prayer go get
em leah go get em